where I was in New York doing the real
live Brady Bunch which was a show that
we did in Chicago reenactments of Brady
bunches
I was Mike Brady I was the dad oh wow
yeah
spitting image no I listen it was
ridiculous I was like yeah buy me we did
we'd done the show in Chicago it was
very popular you know like a rent payer
for the for the theater and then it was
moving to New York and we were at the
Village Gate there and the guy that was
playing Mike Brady
uh wasn't going to go because he had uh
you know like obligations obligations in
Chicago so I was like hey I'll go and so
it was you know a 19 wig later I was
honey I'm homing all over all over the
village was it popular um it was really
popular like it ran in New York I mean
it's it's a very silly dumb idea but it
was the first one of those blank on
stage or blank live you know like you
know like I know they had like uh Point
Break Out Here for years right that's
why
um and it was the first one of those wow
when you're getting your first movies
yeah and you're young yeah because I
remember those days too yeah like
anything's possible yep and I just that
feeling remember that feeling getting a
job getting a job
I mean still getting a job is great
sweet you know yeah yeah
um but that feeling especially and like
you say especially early on when you
don't know if you can do this yeah and
you think like I actually might suck you
know and I mean because I think I still
think like I I kind of think I might
suck you know there are days when I
don't feel so great about myself yeah so
to have that to be like holy [__] you
know I'm here my first my first part in
a movie was one scene in a in a cable
movie remember that woman in Texas that
hired a hit man to kill her teenage
daughter's cheerleading rival and her
mother classic store yeah that's one of
my favorite murderers there were like
two or three main for TV movies about it
and I was in one called
the allegedly true Adventures of the
Texas cheerleader murdering mom which
was pretty legit Holly Hunter Holly
Hunter starred in it whoa and she's
[__] phenomenal in it look it up and
see and Michael Ritchie there's a famous
old 70s movie called smile it's about
beauty pageants and it's if you're like
a big old cult hit and he was he's an
old-time 70s uh director he directed it
and he did a lot so it was really cool
so I was in yeah that's it wow awesome
my first scene was with Beau Bridges and
Swoozie Kurtz at some
like grade school out in the valley that
they turned into a sheriff's office wow
and I you know I was like at home with
my girlfriend and gotten my little
pickup truck my Toyota pickup truck and
drove I felt like I won a contest yeah
yeah I also remember the first scene
yeah like you you go from the trailer
yes right to the set that nerve I don't
know about you oh I have no idea what
yeah and I went to film school you know
like I made a ton of movies I've been on
a ton of sets with commercials because I
was a production assistant yeah but I
still don't really know I don't know how
they make TV shows you know you're
walking there someone's bringing you
there yeah and you're like I don't know
my lines anymore
well I was I played like a and well I
remember when I got cast yeah Michael
Ritchie when I came in he's like yeah
because it was a quick Montage of three
different Deputy sheriffs giving because
Beau Bridges plays the supposed Hitman
who's her ex-brother-in-law or something
like that and